[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of erisa fury i'm kelsey cook and today
i'm very excited I'm joined by somebody
who's been on Conan multiple times you
might know him from The Tonight Show
please welcome Nick Boone okay thank you
[Laughter]
and start excited
so you actually you slid into my DMS and
you said that you would do better than
Kyle did playing me do you remember this
yeah okay
so here we are I know and I realize like
I should have I don't want to talk talk
it up you know like I I actually
realized as I watched through that you
haven't played a good player at all yeah
like nobody's been even good mm-hmm
yeah we've gotten a couple people that
are like a little better than others but
mostly when you said that you thought
you'd be better than Kyle Dunnigan I was
like well that's well that's not even
like yeah maybe triple better than him
okay so what is your foosball background
um I grew up with a table in my house
okay every night my dad and I played a
game before I went to bed which he then
beat me most nights okay you know and
then like physically beat you yeah I
lost yeah yeah and we're still dealing
with that in therapy Wow so this is like
a whole you have a whole family
background with this game I don't think
we've had somebody come on yet that has
like deep roots yeah well then I have
worked at the Boys & Girls Club for six
years as a teen director and they didn't
have a foosball table there and I made
them get one and then I basically like
taught every kid to be really good at
took that foosball oh my god so like
some really good kids and I would
actually have like friends of mine would
come in to like play me in front of the
kids that like we're good and yeah yeah
you know and over the years I've
probably gotten mediocre I mean it's
like you know I don't have a table
anymore don't play it every day okay but
I do have like friends with tables and I
do like to embarrass them in front of
their children every now and again Wow
so do you feel like you will be better
than anybody I've had on so far yeah I
know it's I don't even feel that I just
watched and I know that's kind of
exciting okay and
you think that you can beat me I don't
know I don't know you know it's funny
it's like you probably will beat me but
it's to me it's to me to me it's like
it's like ping pong right right I have a
friend that's really good at ping pong
okay but sometimes I beat him because
I'm not as good as him yeah cuz he can't
play his style of play against me
because I'm slower and so he can't like
get going and do these things like where
is like when you play somebody that is
actually better that's when you're
actually truly playing your style so
when you're playing down I mean that
that doesn't you playing down in
foosball is nothing I have time I feel
like I'm not scoring because I feel bad
for the people and if I just score 10
points within a minute they're gonna be
like all right you know but also I don't
know if you're playing real rules I
don't know if like we're a lot of
different or a lot are we allowed to
score off these guys off the drop you
can but you have to touch two men first
and wait a second yes you can't just
like so I can pass it between two guys
and then store them so I can just drop
in hit exactly okay yeah and obviously
no spins obviously yeah like you know
all that
yeah I've also invented a few moves and
I'm probably you're probably gonna get
to see but also it's a mind game for me
too I mean I I with people in every
game that I play it's a UH do you have
some like there no there's just like
some pictures that you see like a major
league baseball there's like a pitcher
right okay they throw it got it and
there's other pitchers they get the ball
up and they go and then they throw it
because they want to up your timing
because they're allowed to do that
because they've found this little area
in this very established thing that's
been going forever where they can be
unique and actually do something because
there's no rule that says you can't do
that there's rules that you can't step
off the mound and throw because that's a
balk but there's nothing that says you
could sit like this for a minute in the
middle of your pitch like some quick
break yeah you can just watch your legs
up that's all your time so I guess I'm
dropping the ball and that's all my time
I can do whatever I want
well technically you know that there are
time limits oh yeah no but I'm saying
that in that time limit I can do right
or say anything
I have a unique style of play this hand
never moves it's always on the goalie
and I'm stronger with my left and my
right although I am right-handed what is
about to happen I think you'll probably
just have fun playing me because you're
gonna be better than me and I'm and I'm
not gonna be a slouch okay yeah do you
wanna start at the ball why don't you
start with it okay
just for the record I offered for him to
start the ball cool like a nice lady
yeah okay well no because I'm already
noticing a weak spot in your game oh my
god oh my god I really hate you
right why would you have these guys down
just you just wait I know but I'm just
saying like I obviously know that I'm
probably gonna score off one of these
three if the ball comes down here so why
would I I don't want these guys blocking
and I don't need more three more guys
blocking me but just to go I like the
way you do it okay are you ready I had
my hand on and I had a toe on that one
yeah he did that was not a clean goal
but I'm gonna take it okay so you have
to ask if I'm ready are you ready I'm
ready okay okay
I feel like there's not gonna be a lot
of station so you just pick it up and
then you say are you ready again are you
ready you why do you need to do like a
to touch or mm-hmm reset yeah okay yeah
there you go yeah I'm the banker the I
hate thank you I'm an angler and
I'm the banker oh that makes me nervous
oh I take us oh wow okay I usually score
on myself
once a match and then my opponent gets
super excited cuz that's usually the
only point they get so you can do
whatever oh that wasn't an
accidental spin okay it would end up on
my three bar anyway like this so here's
what I don't like about this actually
it's not fair because it's thicker so I
just intuitively know never to grab
something that's thin oh so you guys
this might be a rod
yeah I'm grabbing it because it's out
and it's like it's thick enough you just
got to have that how are you feeling so
far I feel good I don't you don't feel
unbeatable to me and I I I don't feel
unbeatable you're down 3-0
well I scored one of the goals okay um
yeah okay I'll let you have the ball
first a few factors it's your table okay
didn't ask if you were ready scored on
myself this is the quietest a match has
ever been because you genuinely make me
nervous
and I really want to make sure I don't
lose it also would be fun to begin his
first game without you scoring a single
point I'm sorry it doesn't have to stay
in the goal no if you okay that was a
really good game Thank You Wow such
horsemen we usually don't even shake
between games but I appreciate that
mm-hmm okay so now we're gonna so just
like basically why don't you just assess
really quickly like I know I didn't
score you're definitely the best person
I played I'll give you that
mm-hmm of the comics I played so far
let's just do one more of those two five
I know why we have to do three like I
just warmed up you play everyday well we
have we have a structure we're gonna
play another game to five but it's gonna
be a little different it's gonna be
easier for you to beat me I don't I
don't want to do that it's kind of what
the show is though I know but it's not
fair for me to come in cold when you
play every day I came in cool - we
should have warmed up I don't play every
day all right all right no no no it's
it's fine
I don't want to break the rules here
[Music]
do you want to start with it this time
sure okay
are you ready I'm ready
Oh the fake-out
yeah I like the the use of angles we
definitely have not had somebody come on
that intentionally is trying to hit it
[Applause]
you don't have a table right now no I
haven't had a table since I moved out of
my parents house would you consider
getting one now yeah it would I mean I
thought about it a lot and I've looked
online I just don't know why it hasn't
happened
ready yes ready an accident see when you
were telling me before that you didn't
like me keeping my 3 bar down here
mm-hmm do you see why I do that now to
catch the passes and stuff yeah yeah I
guess when you're playing worst people
it blocks goals you know right right
that was good that was Jeff actually
he's uh one of my favorite guys on the
team Jeff solid uh right D give him the
bag so take a point can't score like bad
not take a point ok ready mm-hmm
he was actually good as good goddamn
second third rounds gonna be intense um
I can't remember now it's hard to
compare you to see okay I want to say
right now if you always had your hand on
him that wouldn't have been a goal yeah
maybe but it cuz it just went right I
don't know what his name is good you
failed big on that one I went
right through him
but I scored on you from the back yes
sir I don't know that's I don't think I
could do that but I get your I get the
strategy there do you have a go-to shot
that one that you saw I have a good like
I usually score at this guy off like a
backwards cut yeah see you do a push
yeah okay and then also an angle and a
bank from this guy okay very cool which
I hadn't really had an opportunity for
yet are you ready I'm ready
okay you know there's also another one
that I I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to face against you because you're too
fast but I call it a backfire backfire
as I score up your goalie trying to hit
it and it's a time shot that's very
difficult but once you figure it out
intense it's pretty it's like almost a
score every time I want to show too
that my guy was actually lined up with
your goalie and I and that into the
corner but that's impressive
yeah that is impressive I know it's not
out I'm gonna explain to you when I
scored that's the best type of first
look see what I see why I wanted to play
second game
[Laughter]
that seems to be your you're really good
from that middle guy thank you
are you ready yes you're pretty quick on
D it's hard for me to just like quick
shot on you but that's because you're
saying you always keep a hand on your
left yeah and also I noticed that you
leave open so I just if I was quicker
and smarter yeah last time the ball got
to my goalie while you were still down
here adjusting I should have been able
to score on that yeah that's a strategy
for sure okay ready
mm-hmm it's been doing it yes ready yeah
is it a win by two yeah let's make a win
by two
okay just for good measure just to be
fair okay ready yeah
[Applause]
you don't have also found it's like the
moves that we have that we're good at we
can do them the same every time even
though we think we're not oh yeah yeah
you know like and then people can yeah
anyway but also there's that rule and
truce ball where it's like make them
defend it like keeps scoring it until
they defend it right yeah and then
adjust yeah and like that
I like the pass back I know I haven't
been able to show you but I'm really
strong left like loving my goalie shots
right now
[Applause]
thank God I said 1x2 all right is there
a cap like to seven or it's a tongue we
invite you oh my - okay ready yeah
oh
you almost scored from the back just now
twice that's a back you can't give up
shots like that
nice god dammit oh my god I'm shaking
actually shaking yes no just take the
ball and hold it don't change
do you ever shoot with your going no
never mm-hmm cuz I'm right-handed night
Malibu me - I know but you're saying you
have strong I don't have that strong we
left town okay ready mm-hmm it's that I
can't let you have those guys ready
ready wait we had six nine seven seven
two six okay yeah oh I just want to beat
you again so badly
okay all right you ready ready I
don't give it to that guy I have to
clear my schedule for the rest of the
day out of this game hey ready
damn that left hook is saying up a bang
it's nice bang my bit but my banks are
never planned like that's just a miss
hit that goes up okay ready yep can you
move it to me thank you
wait I'll move away oh just to one of
the nice perfect thank you all right
ready mm-hmm
I really want to get this from the back
I know you do again so you played your
best right I mean for coming in cold and
plain loving thank you
like you don't you weren't like yeah I
really wasn't no I was not trying to
give you anything it's that's the
closest anyone's gotten to beating you
yes
in like a regular game for sure it's
hard to read you you're very like like
what's going on inside right now are you
happy are you mad are you firing no I
like I mean it was a fun game yeah and I
feel like actually kind of cool that I
got that close cool good
[Music]
okay so now we're gonna do round two
we're gonna do a couple things that make
it easier for you to beat me so you want
to come check it out yeah okay come over
here
that's I guess I'll just go around it a
little okay so I'm gonna pick a ball and
then you pick up all okay what's your
number one okay so one this game is that
you you don't have to do anything like
nothing changes for you you get a play
completely normally mm-hmm
and I have to which means I we did this
with Taylor and Delaney I have to make
you or technically I have to make the
loser a gross smoothie while I'm playing
and the loser of everything has to drink
it okay
are you ready yeah okay oh god I hope
you make a good smoothie God do I hope I
still beat you with this happening do
you want to started you want me to start
go for it
ready yeah okay
ha okay this sucks
this really sucks this is not this is
gonna end too quickly
god dammit okay yeah did you score yeah
it was just from this guy don't worry
it's Jeff Jeff I got a problem
with Jeff okay
even if I lose this game just so you
know we play a third round that's winner
takes all
so okay everything's fine yes okay ready
I mean I don't think it's fair to be
honest and that but I'm not the one that
makes the rules you are really starting
to not like you anywhere nice get one
goal for God's sake as a weird
Bank so far this has a banana gravy and
a tomato in it so we're looking good
looking good okay ready
[Applause]
that wasn't Jeff that was Marc but I ate
almost I could see a look on his face
while I was shooting it like I don't
want to do it but here's my chance all
right yeah let's see that baby fire up
I mean you probably need I guess the
gravy's enough moisture please God get
to drink the whole thing I a sip okay
okay yeah I was gonna say that's not
that's not right
you're basically eating baby food you're
gonna have a little puree like this is
what a baby has for dinner they add a
little banana for sweetness a little
gravy for that makes me really drop that
looks so disgusting huh
Oh like so disgusting you beat me so
fast that I didn't have time to even
incorporate and that was for you because
I knew that the longer it took the worst
you had to put in there that's
really nice yeah although I don't feel
like that was entirely for me I feel
like you know I didn't really I realized
that I could tell that you're like okay
but I also know that this is actually
good for you and good for your show
because you put other people through
kind of painful things and so now you
get a real good opportunity to see what
you're putting them through I know and
it's good it's good because next time
you will you have a little more sympathy
for the person that has to eat a dog
bone but I am gonna beat you in this
final round so you are actually gonna be
the one that drinks it so it was good
for you too that you played no wait wait
a second that was based off who won that
game I thought no based on who it's
winner takes all
so we each play we play two games and we
play a third game with two ball are we
doing like an old rule changes in the
middle of the game here no that's good
it always is you know watch the episodes
it's how it always is all right I
promise I promise I promise everyone's
instructed if she'd changed she goes off
to smelled your head yes I swear to God
that was gonna get me but yes okay so we
play two ball now we're technically tied
up one no one said winner of this takes
that takes it all so do you know how to
play two ball no okay
so we each start with the ball here
mm-hmm we go one two three and on go so
one two three go
we both hit it you have to score both
balls to get one point okay Sophie each
score one it's a wash okay and it goes
to five this can take a long time maybe
I don't know I really don't wanna drink
that smoothie so it could be over fast
okay ready mm-hmm
one two three go I feel so good to play
normal fist ball yeah oh my god okay so
wash wash okay ready one two three
wait it's one two three go so one two
three one two three and then we both hit
on go I up no I know it but I
purposely just tap mine because I didn't
want to hit that was actually my
strategy oh I thought you were like
calling me cuz I didn't say go no okay
okay okay so my goal doesn't count then
no I didn't say it right okay okay okay
okay okay
one two three go so you're intentionally
not hitting it yeah
I'll do what I do
all right you got one all right one two
three go wash wash 1 2 3 1 2 3 go 1 2 3
go 1 2 3 go
how you feeling I mean I feel fine I
feel like there's been a little bit of
confusion a goal that I scored that was
taken back oh boy no it's fine it's fine
it's fine you're gonna be sorry about
that well I'm not so I mean it was you
know would you like would you like to
count one of these other girl right now
do you think that's fair
sure I'm beating a 3-0 so you know I'm
feeling kind go for it
[Applause]
ready wash but do you feel yeah I made
an even okay you know when I beat I
don't need to walk away from this
feeling like well she cheated so well I
know because if you think about it this
way like let's say that we're doing an
audition right and you say action and
then I'm actually in character and I'm
like actually note hold on a sec and
then you're like oh cut I'm like no no
that was Mike that's what I'm doing
oh my god so that's what I was doing I
chose not to hit it because I thought it
might be better to actually move over
and defend yours and then come back and
hit mine okay I see mm-hmm hey ready one
two three go man I wish I'd put more
in that smoothie now ready one two
three go
[Applause]
all right one two three go still hanging
in there
you ready one two three go
[Applause]
all right I will say this I am looking
forward to the comments on this video of
me drinking the smoothie because if you
really keep it in like you should the
misunderstanding people are gonna be
like that's it I'm just gonna say I'm
really I'm gonna be for the first time
I'm reading YouTube comments just it
feels slightly validated you do a redo
where I gave you the point and you still
know I'm talking about the
miscommunication I thought that when I
beat you on that you drank this oh the
people in the comments are gonna know
that bad I mean it tastes like vomit
yeah but it looks like vomit - mmm at
least it was all like edible it's all
food yeah I'm telling you you can read
the comments but the people who are
watching it have been watching like
pretty much every episode and they know
it's always their game winner takes all
there's never any punishment that
happens after the second game so I as a
host I apologize if there was any sort
of confusion I'm glad we got that on
camera
but in what in the world of YouTube now
yeah but that it was actually a pleasure
it was really fun to play yeah and I
mean I feel good because I felt like
actually competed a little bit did you
you were great it was I think the
quietest game because I felt like I was
playing a real match and when I feel
like I'm playing a real match there's no
like banter during a regulation game but
I feel like I can talk and you know make
jokes of people when I know that they're
not really playing that hard but you
made us what he gave me a run for my
money I would love to just play with you
again for fun because like to play yeah
let's do it okay all right thank you
cameras but should we hug under we
should hug thank you for doing it well
yes well you plug where people can find
you and and all of that stuff probably
my website are bees calm and I'm on
Twitter and Instagram
no no just find me please find Nick
Boone he's hilarious watch his his late
night sets on YouTube my albums by
Ellen's I'm at Kelsey cut comedy on
Instagram out Kelsey cook on Twitter
Kelsey cook on for tour dates and please
be sure to subscribe to the all thanks
comedy channel go off the other wrist of
fury episodes there's so much fun and
pick up a shirt if you guys want out the
links in the comments below and we'll
see you guys next time bye thank you
guys for watching another episode of
erisa fury
be sure to pick up your official or
wrists of fury shirts that they are
buttery soft they feel like Dalton skin
they're lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you